all right let's talk about this covid
situation because as i said i was just
in texas and in texas you know what a
couple people were wearing masks and god
bless them it's your choice to put
anything on your face if you'd like to
and it's your choice to be injected with
anything if you'd like to i'm cool with
that that's just fine you just can't
tell me what to do with my body which
used to be a thing that the lefties
would say uh but there's all sorts of
crazy things happening uh now
related to coven first i want to show
you um well on a more somber note for
just a moment obviously this past
weekend saturday was uh the 20th
anniversary of 9 11. uh as many of you
know i wrote about it in my book and
i've talked about a few times here i was
in new york city
during 9 11 i did a video that we posted
on locals just about what it was like to
be in new york city at the time and uh
and obviously it's a solemn time and you
know it's hard to imagine that 20 years
later sort of here's where america is at
after that horrific thing
the reason i'm mentioning 911 related to
covet is that they're at one of the
memorials they had obama there and they
had biden and and clinton bill clinton
looks like death walking right now by
the way um but anyway here's joe biden i
want you to just see what he does here
if you don't think that masks and all of
this nonsense is nonsense take a look at
this video watch what he does related to
he has the mask takes off well watch it
the murderers look the murderers
[Music]
[Music]
you're a mod for what you did to
afghanistan
[Music]
terrible terrible
don't snap him
terrible
[Music]
okay so there's a couple things that
happen there first off the reason that
that video went viral was not because of
what happened with the mask it was
because of the people booing him and the
guy that yelled
don't don't sniff him meaning biden
walked with the mask
he has the mask on then when he gets
close to the people to shake their hands
what does he do he takes the mask down
he touches the person right he shakes a
hand and then what's the thing then he
he kisses his own hand can we just come
on
[Music]
terrible terrible
don't snap him
terrible
[Music]
regardless of your feelings on masks in
general and vaccines and everything else
what would be the one thing that maybe
you wouldn't want to do
once you shake somebody's hand if we're
to believe that this pandemic is as bad
as you want especially if you're a what
79 year old guy with i don't want to say
dementia old persons syndrome like he's
got some problems even the way you see
he walks there like this guy's not in
good shape
he takes the mass now when he gets close
to someone he shakes their hand and he
kisses his hand
if imagine if trump did that
imagine if that was trump impeachment
lead of cnn all the usual nonsense that
you know about all right let's show you
video two here we're going to go right
to fouchy now is that what we're doing
which one oh okay so let's let's do a
little bit more on biden so here's just
a little bit of a compilation this is
from rnc research of kamala and biden
saying things about vaccines
before they were the president and vice
president enjoy
so let's just say there's a vaccine that
is approved and even distributed before
the election
would you get it
well i think that's going to be an issue
for all of us if and when the vaccine
comes it's not likely to go through all
the tests that needs to be ended trials
that are needed to be done when we
finally do god willing get a vaccine
who's going to take the shot
who's going to take the shot you can be
the first one to say put me sign me up
they now say it's okay and the question
of whether it's real when it's there
that requires enormous transparency
you got to make all of it available to
other experts across the nation
so they can look and see
so there's consensus this is a safe
vaccine if the president announced
tomorrow we have a vaccine would you
take it
only if it was completely transparent
that other experts in the country could
look at it only if we knew all of what
went into it if donald trump can't give
answers an administration can't give
answers to these three questions the
american people should not have
confidence but if donald trump tells us
i should that we should take it i'm not
taking it you know if it was hard for
you to watch those clowns say those
things that if they said those things
now they'd probably be banned from
twitter or you know just kicked out of
polite society if it's hard for you to
watch that we have to watch it a couple
times when we're setting up the show and
my director conor turned to me in the
middle of that one and said how is this
guy president like that's what we're all
realizing how is this guy president i
actually don't think he's president i
mean i know it says it on his desk or on
the paper that he's always looking at
like i believe he was sworn in as
president united states but he's
obviously not the guy in charge anyway
the point is when trump was the one that
was doing operation warp speed and we're
going to get everybody vaccinated and
everything else uh kamala harris i don't
trust it i don't trust trump joe biden
who would trust this it has to be
transparent do you feel that everything
feels transparent right now like the
level of lies with these people is
absolutely extraordinary and they know
they can do it because the media runs
cover for them and i would say the
bigger problem at this point and i think
my track record on this has been pretty
good is that it's never going to stop
until we stop it and i don't even know
exactly what that means through
elections or just like some sort of
national divorce or whatever else but
meaning
you could watch videos from i think
probably by the end of march of 2020
where i kept saying the old world is not
coming back and it's becoming very very
clear that's not coming back like it's
gone it's gone try to remember your life
if you can
i'll do a five seconds of silence here
try to remember your life back in
january of 2020 do you even remember it
it's kind of hard right it's kind of
hard to remember what it was like before
this but i know it was better than this
nonsense that we're dealing with now and
they're just gonna keep coming and if
you don't think so well here's uh fauci
now talking about mandating that
everyone who gets on a plane should have
to wear a mask if we get the
overwhelming proportion of the
population vaccinated we will get to
hurt immunity if we do it in the next
six months it will happen in the next
six months if we do it in the next two
months it'll happen in the next two
months i would support that if you want
to get on a plane and travel with other
people that you should be vaccinating
when you hear us say should you mandate
vaccination for children to be able to
attend school
some people say oh my goodness that
would be terrible to do that but we
already do that and have been doing that
for decades and decades i don't know
what school you went to but the school
that i went to you had to be vaccinated
for measles mumps rubella polio or
otherwise you couldn't go to school
so it is not something new
to mandate vaccines for school children
the solution that we have at our hands
is vaccines
measles mumps and rubella kill people
including young people covid does not
again i don't want to send anyone to
twitter but go look at my twitter i just
retweeted something by congressman
massey
from kentucky about the ages of people
that are dying and young people are just
simply not dying i know that makes
people upset when you say that but
they're not they're not dying young
people have immunity healthy people have
immunity we never talk about stop being
a fat [ __ ] and eat right and take care
of yourself and try medicine uh try
eating right you know not drinking all
the time not taking drugs not abusing
yourself and you might be okay your
immunity might be okay uh notice how
they've also changed the language it was
two weeks to flatten the curve now it's
quite literally almost two years later
it's over a year and a half later and
it's we don't talk about flattening the
curve nobody even if you were even to
say flatten the curve like if someone
was to bring that up on cnn they
wouldn't even know what to do with it
but we went from two weeks to flatten
the curve to literally he's saying in
two months if everyone gets vaccinated
we'll have hurt immunity or it could be
in six months if everyone gets back they
will hurt immunity they're just pushing
and pushing and pushing and pushing